salut romain romana gas tu fais je suis
à celle en n'accordant que tu mesure 1 m
je sais bien que tu mens pourrais tu
fais ça tu fais toujours passer pour un
con dre nacro j'en ai marre c'était pour
moi c'est pas loin
roma ne reviens je te demande pardon
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez déjà croisé un
géant je veux dire à part dans les
animés ou sur les boîtes de maïs c'est
très possible que non parce que c'est
très rare mais ça existe alors il n'y a
pas vraiment une taille à partir de
laquelle on est considéré comme un géant
mais statistiquement on dit qu'une
personne est atteinte de gigantisme
c'est comme ça que ça s'appelle quand sa
taille est supérieure aux derniers
centiles de la population c'est des
stats c'est compliqué bon en gros c'est
quand on est beaucoup plus grand que les
très bons pour vous donner quelques
exemples
l'homme le plus grand jamais identifié
s'appelait robert roy de l'eau et il
mesurait deux mètres 72 lui vous ne
recevez pas parce que il est mort en
1940 si vous voulez croiser un géant
vous pouvez allez payer un verre à
sultane cause n qui est avec ses 2 m 51
l'homme le plus grand encore en vie
identifié par le guinness book des
records par contre sont allés en turquie
mais c'est joli et la turquie et les
belles choses à voir aller
[Musique]
la plus grande fan de tous les temps
était une chinoise nommée zain gillian
elle mesurait deux mètres 46 à 2 m 48
selon les sources et elle est morte en
1982 attention médicalement parlant il
ya plusieurs cas de figure il ya des
gens qui sont juste très grand c'est
comme ça c'est le cas par exemple de gao
ning terrain ancien basketteur chinois
qui a fait sa carrière nba chez les
houston rockets mais je suis sûr que
vous avez déjà vu ça peut être quelque
part c'est de mettre 29 s'explique par
le fait que sa mère mesurait un mètre 88
et son père 2008 s'étaient tous les deux
des basketteurs chinois ça fait quand
même un beau bagage génétique
d'ailleurs la légende raconte que leur
faire faire un bébé c'était imprimantes
et du parti communiste chinois pour
créer un sportif surdimensionné sega
mais les parents de tous les géants ne
sont pas des géants parce que pour
certains c'est un peu plus compliqué que
ça certaines personnes de très grande
taille sont atteintes de ce qu'on
appelle l'acromégalie accroc ça veut
dire extrémités et mégalithes
ça veut dire bon c'est une maladie rare
qui touche majoritairement les adultes
et qui se manifeste par un élargissement
des os et des tissus des mains des pieds
et de la tête des extrémités
cette maladie elle est causée par une
sorte de tumeur un adénome situé dans
l'hypophyse qui se trouve juste là au
niveau du cerveau et qui fabrique
plusieurs hormones et notamment
l'hormone de croissance et à cause de
settat dénombra elle se met à en
fabriquer tron alors vous allez me dire
là on parle que des extrémités avoir des
grandes mains et chaussées du 52e ça
fait par un géant alors c'est vrai mais
la maladie peut aussi toucher des
enfants et les enfants ils ont sur les
eaux un cartilage qu'on appelle le
cartilage de conjugaison ou cartilage de
croissance et qui permet aux haut de ses
tirs et donc de grandir à la puberté ses
cartilages il se soude et c'est pour ça
que la croissance s'arrête mais avant ça
s'il a d'énormes fait augmenter la
production d'hormones de croissance les
eaux y grandissent y grandissent et ça
donne une forme particulière de la
maladie qui s'appelle l'acromégalie
gigantisme des géants des personnes
célèbres atteints d'acromégalie
gigantisme on en trouve dans le milieu
du cinéma avec par exemple richard kiel
deux mètres 18 célèbre pour son rôle de
shark
donc james bond ou encore mathieu ma
grand rideau m 29 qui joue car le géant
dans big fish mais qui joue aussi dans
men in black 2 où dans la maison des
1000 morts de revenus mais des géants on
en trouve aussi dans le sport dans le
basket par exemple avec georges news and
2 m 31 ans passé par le championnat de
france et la nba ou encore andré rené
rousse imhoff un catcheur français de
deux mètres 24 plus connu sous le nom de
andré le géant
alors petit aparté ya une rumeur qui dit
que c'est andré le géant qui a inspiré
le personnage de shrek
apparemment c'est une déformation d'une
autre rumeur qui concerne un autre
catcheur français qui s'appelle maurice
tillet dit l'ange français même là ça
n'a pas été confirmée même s'ils n'ont
par contre ce qu'on sait c'est que nous
reste il ya étaient aussi atteints
d'acromégalie
mais pas d'accroc mégalo gigantisme
parce que il mesurait un mètre soixante
dix pour être tout à fait honnête il
faut dire que l'acromégalie c'est pas la
seule maladie légère une très grande
taille ça peut aussi être une des
conséquences du syndrome de marfan dont
on a déjà parlé dans une vidéo c'est le
cas par exemple de peter may you 2 m 21
célèbre pour avoir joué chewbacca mais
bref donc l'acromégalie dans l'enfance
ça allonge les eaux et à l'âge adulte ça
les épaissir mais c'est pas les seules
conséquences de la maladie au niveau du
visage
l'élargissement ils concernent les eaux
comme le feront les arcades sourcilières
le menton mais aussi les tissus au
niveau du nez ou des lèvres par exemple
cette augmentation de volume elle peut
aussi toucher les muscles le larynx
ce qui donne souvent une voix assez rock
est assez grave et d'autres organes
comme le foie ou le coeur par exemple
mais parce que la dénommée puits à
l'origine de la maladie
c'est une tumeur bénigne dans la mesure
où ses parts à cancer mais il a quand
même d'autres conséquences sur la santé
en plus des problèmes osseux il ya aussi
un retentissement au niveau cardiaque et
des difficultés à réguler le taux de
sucre et le taux de graisse par exemple
évidemment tout ça ça arrive
progressivement donc c'est pas toujours
très faciles à détecter
mais par contre ça se soigne soit on
retire la tumeur en passant par le nez
généralement autant vous dire que c'est
une opération long
est délicate mais ça marche bien à
condition que la des normes soient
suffisamment petit on peut aussi faire
de la radiothérapie des rayons si vous
voulez qu'ils sont envoyés directement
sur la tumeur pour la faire diminuer le
volume c'est plus long pour avoir des
résultats est généralement celle
utilisée en plus de l'opération ou des
médicaments
parce que oui il ya des médicaments qui
font baisser leurs zones de croissance
mais ils peuvent avoir des effets
secondaires plus ou moins important
surtout si on les prend donc c'est pour
ça que le plus souvent on les utilise en
complément de l'opération voire des
rayons l'idée c'est de réduire la taille
de la tumeur voire de la faire
disparaître et d'atteindre des taux
d'hormones de croissance les plus
proches possibles de la normale et puis
évidemment on peut soigner les
conséquences de la maladie comme le
diabète ou d'hypertension artérielle
mais les géants en face b g voilà dtc
c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]